انفاق القطاع تواجه مياه البحر كيف ذلك
واشنطن تعلن تغيير الجيش العبري لتكتيكات
حرب القطاع مستشار الامن ووزير الدفاع
الامريكيان في طريقهما الى تل ابيب قطر
ترد على المسؤولين العبريين وتواصل دعمها
للقطاع ومدينه عربيه اصبحت ملاذا
لملياردير العالم الولايات المتحده تعلن
تصميمها انشاء جيش اوكراني لا يقهر
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تهدد بولندا سلوفاكيا
بسبب اوكرانيا وزيلينسكي في مهمه صعبه في
واشنطن للحصول على الدعم العسكري وموسكو
تعلق لن يسعفكم ذلك ليرد بايدن لا ينبغي
للكونجرس ان يمنح بوتين هديه عيد
الميلاد الانفاق تواجه
البحار يمضون بخططهم المعلنه لا شيء يوقف
العبريين حتى المجتمع الدولي لم تفد
قراراته منذ بدء الحرب في القطاع وما دامت
تل ابيب تمتلك الفيتو الامريكي فالحرب
ستمتد لوقت اطول هكذا يقول شعب القطاع هنا
قالت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال نقلا عن
مسؤولين امريكيين لم تذكر اسمائهم ان
الجيش العبري بدا ضخ مياه البحر في مجمع
انفاق الفصائل في القطاع واضافت ان
العمليه ستستغرق على الارجح اسابيع واوضحت
الصحيفه ان بعض مسؤولي اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن يقولون ان العمليه قد
تساعد في تدمير الانفاق التي تعتقد تلبيب
ان الفصائل تخفي رهائن ومعتقلين ومقاتلين
وذخائر بداخلها ليخرج المكتب الصحفي
لحكومه تلبيب بتصريح ان 19 من بين
135 محتجزا لا يزالون في القطاع قتلوا وان
احدهم تنزاني الجنسيه دون ان يذكر اسمه
وقالت تنزانيا ان اثنين من مواطنيها
وكلاهما من طلاب الزراعه كان من بين نحو
240 ره اقتيد الى القطاع في اكتوبر من
جانب اخر اكد وزير الدوله القطري للشؤون
الخارجيه محمد الخليفي في تصريحات لشبكه
سي ان ان الامريكيه استمرار قطر في دعم
القطاع ماليا ما بعد الحرب وسط انتقادات
لاذعه لها من مسؤولين عبريين بينما ذكر
موقع ينات انه من المقرر ان يصل وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن ومستشار الامن
القومي جيك سيلوفان الى تل ابيب الاسبوع
المقبل ميدانيا كرت فاينانشال تايمز ان
الولايات المتحده تتوقع ان تقوم الابي
بتغيير تكتيكاتها القتاليه في القطاع
بحلول شهر يناير المقبل بحيث تقلص نطاق
هجومها البري وتقلل من كثافه غارتها التي
ستصبح اكثر دقه وتستهدف كبار قاده الفصائل
والاهداف الاستراتيجيه الكبيره القيمه
وحسب هذا واصدرت الفصائل في بياناتها
اليوميه المنفصله انها تخوض اشتباكات
ضاريه على محاور التوغل مع الجيش العبري
بشان مسار المعارك الضاريه في خان يونس
وحي الشجاعيه اعلنت عن تدمير عدد من
الاليات وقتل جنود عبريين تزامنا مع قصف
حشود عبريه داخل القطاع وفي غلافه وبعيدا
عن الحرب وعلى مدى عقود اختار اثرياء
العالم حمايه اصولهم في مناطق تتوزع بين
جزر كايمان وسويسرا وجزر العذراء
البريطانيه لكن مركزا جديدا للثروه اصبح
يحظى بشعبيه كبيره في اوساط المليارديرات
شير وكاله بلومبرغ الى ان ابو ظبي الاماره
المكتظه بالابراج الشاهقه اصبحت ملاذا
لثروات مليارديرات
العالم موقف واشنطن
المحير الموقف الامريكي يتغير من يوم لاخر
اذا كانت اوكرانيا هي القضيه ليؤكد هنا
وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن ان
الولايات المتحده مصممه على مساعده
اوكرانيا على انشاء قوات مسلحه قادره على
احتواء روسيا في المستق بل مضيفا ان دعم
واشنطن لكيف لن يتزعزع نحن مصممون على
مساعده اوكرانيا على القتال والدفاع عن
اراضيها ومواطنيها حتى ان صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز افادت ان البنتاجون سوف يرسل الفريق
انطونيو اوجو الى كياف لتطوير استراتيجيه
عسكريه جديده للجيش الاوكراني من جانبه
اصبح للرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
في مهمه صعبه في واشنطن للحصول على الدعم
العسكري حيث يلتقي في البيت الابيض الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ليقول الرئيس الامريكي
لنظيره الاوكراني لا اريدك ان تفقد الامل
مضيفا انه لا ينبغي للكونغرس ان يمنح
بوتين هديه عيد الميلاد فيما اعرب زيلنسكي
في اجتماعه برؤساء شركات الدفاع الامريكي
استعداد المجمع الصناعي العسكري الاوكراني
لزياده انتاج الاسلحه والذخيره مجددا
مطالبه واشنطن بدعم عسكري ومالي اضافي
هناك اكد الكرملن ان لقاء الرئيسين
الامريكي والاوكراني في واشنطن لن يغير من
مسار العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وان ضخ المليارات لن يسعف كياف
في اوروبا اعلن وزير الزراعه الهنغاريه
اشتفان ناد ان المفوضيه الاوروبيه هددت
هنغاريا وبولندا وسلوفاكيا باتخاذ اجراءات
قانونيه ضدهم لفرضه حذرا احاديا على توريد
الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى اسواقها اما في
روسيا فصرحت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
ماريا زاخاروفا ان استبدال زيلنسكي
بالقائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
فاليري زالو جيني او اي سياسي اوكراني اخر
لن يغير الوضع لانهم جميعا دم في ايدي
الدول الغربيه فيما اعلن نائب رئيس
الوزراء الروسي مراد حسن وولين بدء اعداد
خطه لاعاده اعمار مدينه ماريوبول المحرره
في جمهوريه دونيسك الروسيه للعام المقبل
على الارض الاوكرانيه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قيام ادقم الطائره المسيره وانظمه
الصواريخ المضاده للدبابات فاجوت التابعه
للمج المجموعه الغربيه الروسيه برصد
وتدمير مركز قياده ومراقبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه لتعلن الوزاره الروسيه الحصيله
اليوميه بالقضاء على اكثر من 700 عسكري
اوكراني واسقاط 23 مسيره اوكرانيه على
مختلف المحاور خلال 24
[موسيقى]
ساعه
مع
[موسيقى]
بض
ه